Sharkey: Hi.
My name is Jeff Sharkey.
And I'm a student
from Montana State University.
I wrote an Android application
called CompareEverywhere.
And I'd like to show it to you
on my phone today.
Let's go ahead and get it
started up.
And when we open it,
we have three different options.
We could scan a barcode,
run a full text search,
or look at lists of items
that we might have stored
before in the past.
In this case, I found a CD
that I'm interested in.
We can tap and scan
the barcode with our phone.
So in this case,
we found
several different options
for going out and buying
this item.
We can look through
that list.
We see there's several
online stores,
and also some local stores
in our neighborhood,
as well as a local library
that we could go
and borrow the item.
In this case, we can also map
those local stores
to look at all
of the different options.
If I know I'm going down
to a neighborhood later today,
I could zoom in to see what
stores are available in the area
and what prices they have.
In this case, I'm interested
in this store.
I can tap on that
and I can look at
see driving directions
to the store location
or I could call them
to make sure
that they actually have it
in stock.
I can also look at lists
of items.
So let's say
like a shopping list
as I walk through
the store.
If I know I need to pick up
a certain number of items.
I can easily cross those items
off my list as I buy them
as I walk through the store.
So I got the idea
for this application
a couple years ago
as I was watching a documentary.
I saw an employee in a store
scan a barcode
and be able to check
the inventory that they had
in the back room as well as
the pricing they'd had
over the past couple years.
I thought to myself,
why couldn't people everywhere
have that kind of functionality
on their phones
as they walk through stores?
So to build
this application,
I used several different
APIs pieced together.
I used the camera
that's built into the phone
along with the ZXing library,
which is an Open Source library
written by several people
at Google, uh,
to decode the barcodes.
I also used
the Google Maps API
to be able to show the local
stores in a person's area.
And finally, I used
the location manager
to make sure that we
always select local stores
that are around the user.
In all, using those APIs,
it only took me
about two white--
two weeks to write.